Drought has destroyed the harvest in southern Madagascar for four straight years...
...and sandstorms made it next to impossible to replant the fields.
Bole has three children as well as two orphans she took in.
Every day is a fight for survival.
I trust in God.
Today, we have absolutely nothing to eat except cactus flowers,...
...which we are trying to clean.
The children here, their mother died and so did my husband.
The World Food Programme says...
...acute malnutrition among children under five has doubled in just five months.
In one district, a quarter of all children are malnourished.
All told, more than one million people need help.
Northern Ethiopia has also long depended on aid.
Last year, there was a plague of locusts, then the war.
More and more people require assistance,...
...but many areas in the interior away from the cities are inaccessible.
People have lost their assets and money.
So people are still in a very vulnerable situation...
...trying to manage with the farmers, potentially with a few stocks that they had.
We know that people are not having seeds to plant...
...or they potentially might be missing another harvest.
If the next harvest is also lost,...
...people like this farming couple will also have to turn to the aid agencies.
Across Africa, the number of those forced to flee drought,...
...violence and climate change, is on the rise.